good evening everybody and welcome to
tonight's um
meeting of the stratford university
council planning committee my name is
danny kendall i will be chairing
tonight's meeting in accordance with the
rules and procedures as they're set out
in the uh front page of your agenda
tonight before we get started a couple
of bits of housekeeping if that's okay
just to make members of the public aware
of the fact that tonight's meeting is
being recorded and will be available for
you to review anytime you like on the
couch website after this evening also if
i could ask a members committee and
members of the public to make sure their
phones are turned off or silent that
would be excellent as well
and i think
that's all i want to say in terms of
housekeeping at the beginning
i'll introduce people at the front at
the top table if that's okay as well on
my far right is olivia quinn from
committee services then mason nash who
is our legal representative tonight on
my immediate left is richard gardner
who's our planning manager then we have
joe brooks sarah chadwick and amy flute
who are
planning officers first tonight and uh
paul harris and matt neil who will help
us on one of our applications tonight
which i believe is item
item five no item four apologies i might
think it's fallen off there so
right that's done let's move them to
apologies
oh sorry richard you're asking each
other
thank you mr chairman uh just to confirm
my role tonight and that is to provide
impartial advice to committee members
and to assist them in their decision
taking thank you
thank you apologies for missing your
offer right now we have to apologize for
absence
um chair we've got apologies from
councillors richards adam crump dixon
and foreman
thank you
right disclosure of interests i'll keep
this one off if that's all right so on
the uh on application reference
two 21-028 uh five four slash o u t
um i have a
non-punery um interest to declare on
that however i have sought and been
granted a dispensation from our
monitoring officer today so i will be
able to continue with that meeting are
there any other members who would share
that particular declaration councilman
mills
sorry joining us exactly the same as you
mr chairman same one thank you
councillor jennings
councillor fleming okay thank you any
other disclosure of interests yes uh joe
can i can we ask what that
interest is
i'll defer to the legal officer if
that's okay on that one
the answer on that just so i have the
specific reasons why
um
i'll see if i can find the email from
the monitoring officer it's been
published on the website but we can read
out the precise wording for you in a
moment if you like
absolutely any other disclosure of
interests
nope excellent in that case minutes of
the meeting held on the 18th of may are
you content that i signed those as a
true record of the meeting every agreed
thank you very much i'll just make sure
that happens later
right
slight change to the running order of
the meeting of the meeting i think um
the say our second application which
would have been item five um the
none of the the ward member hasn't
registered to speak the parish council
hasn't registered to speak and the
application was only here because it had
been sparked by the parish council in
that case our usual practices in those
instances that we delegate the uh
application back to officers to decide
uh are you all content that we delegate
that to officers i'll propose it
secondly by councillor jennings and
agreed by
by all thank you
okay so that is uh application reference
two two zero zero zero three six slash
ful that is delegated to officers and uh
we won't have to deal with tonight
okay
back to our usual running order then so
we have item four which is our first
application this evening this is
twenty one
zero two eight five four slash out
and this is the
washington and is the outline
application for the construction of up
to nine self-building custom-built
dwellings and creation of two new
vehicle access points on collingham lane
i'll pause before we go to uh joe brooks
see if it's if we're there yet it's a
long dispensation no it isn't
six conservative members of the planning
committee have asked me to grant them a
dispensation to participate in public
application reference 2102 854 out
which is before the committee on the
22nd of june the members concerned are
councillors jennings richards kendall
mills crump and fleming
the planning applicant applicant is
roscon strategic unlimited which is part
of the roscon group limited
evidence from the electoral commission
website shows that between september
2015 and june 2019
rdl made donations to the conservative
party toting 33 688
pounds and it's it's broken down
the last donation was made on the 10th
of june 2019.
the sdc code of conduct requires members
to disclose in the pressure of interest
maintained by the monitoring officer
details of anybody which they are a
member or in a position of general
control or management and whose
principal purposes include the influence
of public opinion or policy including
any political party
i can go on so basically that's the
dispensation thank you that's good you
can't tempt you understand the nature of
the dispensation yes i do and i think
it's very helpful for members of the
public to understand that as well
thank you very much
okay in that case we go to presenting
officer on this application joe brooke
joe it's over to you thank you chair uh
let me just set everything up
the site is located on the outer edge of
longitude along collin lane as indicated
by the black dot before you
the site is an outline application for
the development of up to nine self build
and custom build dwellings and the
creation of two new vehicle accesses
from column and lane
approval sort for access our own stage
only
so as indicated before you the red line
boundary is the side plan this is column
lane
this is the siphon road and that is
stockton road that leads just office so
from road extends that way this is the
edges of conservation area just for
clarity
the site equates to 0.7 hectares of
greenfield land as indicated and
residential development is situated
direct to the west south of the
application site opposite side of column
lane so once again
these existing dwellings that extend
along the southern road this is colin
lane so the application site's here as
you can see before you these are the
plot layouts if the application was
permitted
uh the plots are arranged in a linear
form front and onto column and lane
these areas would become part of a
management scheme
and this area to the north would be part
of the biodiversity offset all this is
in the report
so these are this is the perimeters plan
so i'll quickly go through some of the
aspects but it is detailed um heavily
within the report
so linear form
the development will take place within
the perimeters as set out in the plan
seventy percent of the build area will
be fronting onto the development fied um
active frontages three and four will
also find some active frontages looking
onto the related access point
to ensure that front gardeners must be
defined by the means of low boundary
enclosures compromising of hedges fences
metal railings which will be no more
than 1.2 meters
uh
the design code states also eastern will
be designed so the built form would only
occupy land within the build area so as
i've already described and committed um
the perimeters and as you can see there
is um gaps between each printer
at a minimum
also noble big performance when one
meter have any plot boundary no built
form will be starting within three
meters of any clock bearing in front in
a street or shared driveway and
dwellings must not result in a
separation distance between the side
side elevations of less than three
meters minimum private garden depths of
10.5 meters all this was is within the
design and access
in the design code sorry that's been
submitted and is set out in the office
report under the landscape and design
character section
so now we go to the site itself so the
photos before you these are the
dwellings that you can see
front and on just for clarity i'll come
back on so this is obviously the haven
and bright mirror the two there
so coming back on
that's the haven as you can see just
behind his bright mirror
that's the application site once again
front and on from it this is the open
parcel and so the right hand side with
the widow trees this is colin lane's
um
area also i do have some videos which
i'll go into in two seconds
so this is taking down column lane start
stretching into longitudinal uab is
situated build a pair of boundaries for
clarity
just there would be the haven you can
just see the boundary details
i've gone the wrong way this is leading
up to column lane so the site is on to
the left-hand side this is the ribbon
development along column rain across the
road
this is taken from the prowl to the
north and i will show you some more of
this in a minute so let me just do it so
everybody can see quite clearly
if i zoom in which is most of them do
that is common lane development coming
across
these you can just see the rooftops of
the hoses are situated along
southland road and stockton roads just
behind there and the application site
will be cited within just behind there
and i've got videos to even more clarity
in two seconds so
just for officers but when it uploads
just rosters perspective this is the
application so i i have 10 videos but i
i'm going to show the three most
perspective but by all means if you
request more please do let me know
uh i will be showing videos uh nine
five and three for the perspective but i
said i'll be showing more so let me go
to that right now
wish to start with three
i do apologize unfortunately just take a
bit of time to upload
so
so this is just entering into the
parents of the field that i've just
shown
as you can see the site is
coming back
pause it for office clarification the
site is situated around there
so that's the first video now we will go
to three seven
to five
now as you can see column lane there
that is the application site
this is all pro so it's all in the
public domain um i public for probably
public footpath
that's the application site there
and there's public footpath
no nines along common lane i will
actually show one within the site so
just so you know exactly what the site
looks like and this was taken this week
as well
so this is extension down column lane
the site is situated behind this
boundary details as you can see down
there
is long itchington and this just gives
you an indication of the ribbon
development across the road
and then last but not least is within
the upper occasion so itself
so that's colin lane there
that's me just coming into the area
column lanes straight across you can see
the dwellings along
siphon road
the boundary details of the um
trees that exist in that's the rear of
the application site
and that's a small hut that is on the
site
and i'll just go back to the
presentation
in summary as with all applications the
currency required to make a decision in
line with the development plan unless
material considerations indicate
otherwise the stratfor uneven core
strategy forms the adopted development
plan in this instance its most important
policies do not make any reference to
self build and custom house building and
therefore they hold moderate weight a
material consideration is that the
council is legally obliged to maintain a
role in supply of self and custom build
plots the existence this shortfall holds
significant weight a further material
consideration is the ndp but like the
core strategy its most important
policies do not cover the provision for
self-build custom house building and is
therefore hold moderate weight the sap
is also a material consideration and
whilst it does seek to address the
provision itself and custom build it
carries limited weight oh into its early
stages of preparation
consequently having considered the
area's development plan all relevant
material planning considerations and the
level of weight which can be attributed
to both the adopted and emerging policy
as set out and paragraph 48 the
framework i consider the principle
development is acceptable and therefore
the recommendation is to grant outline
permission
and to not contest any appeals should it
be confirmed
as you can see on the update sheet there
is a few amendments and uh reference to
a recommendation uh thank you
thank you joe and i think that excellent
presentation i think that brings me to
the next point for the members of the
community before we go to our speakers
there are it's quite a long kind of
lengthy update sheet so i'm going to
pause and i know before the meeting
started and i saw a lot of you reading
through this but i think i'm just going
to make sure i give you just a couple of
minutes now to again go through the
update sheet and the adjoining appendix
at the end as well to make sure you've
had more than enough time to appreciate
and look through all the details so just
pause for a couple of minutes for you to
again refresh yourselves on those
uh happy that they've had enough time to
look through that and they understand
everything in the update sheet
a lot of nods from around the table okay
thank you in that case let's move to our
first speaker if that's okay uh that's
uh it's councillor john venn please from
long itchington parish council
welcome
[Applause]
right so if you press the button in the
middle uh that's perfect so i can see
the red lights on you've got three
minutes to speak if you'd remain seated
for any questions that the committee may
have at the end that would be fantastic
and we'll give you a warning in the last
30 seconds of your time
over to you
thank you
the situation is simple and our legal
advice is clear
planning decisions can only be based on
policy and law
your office has acknowledged that
paragraph 11d of the nppf is not
triggered as relevant development plan
policies apply
the development plan can only be set
aside if substantial material grounds
exist
officers propose self-built housing as a
material ground
which we reject
you have no policy on self build the
giraffe sap only commenced regulation 18
consultation last week and carries
minimal weight
in the absence of policy the law must be
the guide
the self-built legislation and ppg
provide precise guidance on the
calculation of supply and demand
when correctly applied this demonstrates
that the district council is meeting its
duties under the self-built act
as the legal requirement of self-bill is
being met this cannot represent a
material grounds to justify setting
aside the development plan which applies
in full
the application must be rejected
that officers have chosen a different
measure of supply and demand with no
basis in law
is immaterial and carries no weight
further the site is specifically
identified in the evidence base of the
core strategy to be avoided this has not
been addressed and the key information
has been excluded from the report
the demand for plots on multiple
self-build sites is not established and
there is a real risk that these plots
will end up being sold as open market
housing
roscon has lobbied for the marketing
period to be as short as possible
this is a highly unusual site a hay
meadow undisturbed for generations and
rich in wildlife
the ecology studies are flawed
one-third of the world's land carbon is
stored in undisturbed grassland we owe
it to future generations to protect such
sites such as these
the application fails to comply with the
key core strategy policies and i ask you
to take cancer the following in reaching
your decision
cs15 and cs16 housing numbers
long itchington has received 310
dwellings
285
above the adjusted target the highest
over provision in the district
policy as10 applies as the site lies
outside the buab
cs5 landscape the site is specifically
identified as to be avoided for
development
the application does not comply with ndp
policy h1 and our neighborhood plan
carries more weight than the draft sap
paragraph 11d of the nppf is not
triggered
on these strong planning grounds please
save this undisturbed meadow and reject
the application thank you
thank you
okay do we have any questions from the
committee please councillor mills
hi council event um
was there any consultation
on this with the residence or parish
council from the developer
um
not on this application i suppose the
consultation um was on the sap which we
responded to
and in our sap response we highlighted
the fact that the site is identified in
the landscape sensitivity assessment is
to be avoided for development
and that is a point which is not
addressed we raised it in our
application
uh response
objection response and it isn't
addressed adequately if at all in your
offices report i hope that answers the
question
ample thank you any further questions
from the committee yes council curtis
thank you
thank you council event um
a couple of things that you said you you
mentioned that
key i think these both um around
environmental issues the key information
was excluded from the report
and the ecology study was flawed i
wonder if you could clarify what key
information
was excluded you feel and in what ways
the
ecology study has been flawed
okay could i deal with the ecology study
first if i take that thank you um so
in
in 2021 the parish council was
initiating an ecology study of the
village to be done by the warwickshire
biological record center
we wanted this site covered because of
its unique nature
and i approached roscoen for permission
to access the site for the study to be
undertaken
roscon refused and they said there was
no need for any study because a totally
adequate study had been
conducted and they provided a copy of
that study
we shared that with warwickshire
wildlife trust
and they identified a number of
significant flaws particularly i won't
give you attractiveness detail but
particularly that as a grassland site
the study was conducted in october and
c-i-e-m guidance says
this must be done in basically june
so we responded to that and highlighted
the points and along with a number of
others
roscon said they'd share them with their
ecologists
and again refuses access to the site
and we um they when they eventually
provided the alternative report
it was
totally different from the previous
report the previous report was stated
this to be no need for any further study
to be undertaken
it highlighted far more biodiversity
than the original
however we still believe it's flawed
because there's no mention for example
of pollinators
in the study and although we can't
access the site we've been monitoring it
from the sidelines and it's absolutely
swarming with butterflies and other
pollinators
i won't give you more detail but there
are loads of other reasons why but the
the ecology study remains flawed
sorry
yes
right so sorry if i went on
so the um we highlighted it in our uh
letter to the committee
under landscape where we drew um in
where we drew attention
to the landscape sensitivity assessment
and particularly the report that's been
conducted by allison frost
now the officer report
references paragraphs 5.17 and 5.18 of
the frost report
and the impression from reading those
statements is that the 14 fields of the
land parcel some of those 14 fields
may be suitable for development
and the impression gained from the
reader is that this field is one of
those fields but i will just finally
read you paragraph
5.20 which is admitted from the report
it's the gladman site is separated from
the existing built edge of the north
side of cullingham lane by the small
pasture with the stream mature willow
trees as well as remnant ridge and
furrow
this field is specifically mentioned and
the lcp sensitivity text has to be
avoided now we struggle to understand
how when the other paragraphs are quoted
this which is so salient and critical
and references the landscape sensitivity
assessment
part of the evidence-based the course
strategy is completely ignored
okay
counselor jennings
have you identified any areas
for self-built in your ndp
um
we
the mdp doesn't mention um self bills we
we were silent on on on that and that
was fully accepted by the examiner it's
not to say that we're against self-built
we're not
we believe that our existing policies
within the neighborhood development plan
sufficiently cover
any self-built application that might
come forward such as this so we don't
see that it's a major admission from the
neighborhood plan and it's not a factor
as to why
that's okay i think you've probably
answered the question more than enough
uh yes council hench the seraphim okay
um
is this meadowlands susceptible to any
flooding at all
the the stream that runs through it
which on that photograph runs down on
the right hand side
does flood it's not a ditch as described
in some of the correspondence it's a
spring-fed
stream um and the there is a there is a
high risk flood level running through it
now your officers will obviously say to
you and we accept this that the site i
think houses i think again you've
probably answered the question which was
does it flood so that's okay any further
questions from the committee
no that's okay that case thank you very
much for your time this evening thank
you
okay we can move to our next speaker
to give you a moment uh which is liz
nicholson agent for the applicant please
welcome hello right so you have three
minutes as well you know the routine if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end over to you
we're very grateful to your officers for
all their hard work to enable this
application to be brought to committee
tonight
we've made every effort to work with
your officers to resolve the technical
matters in respect to this site key
issues being foul and surface water
drainage highways matters and ecology
and biodiversity
just taking the one issue of drainage
the surface water management proposals
have been modeled and independently
verified and there are no objections
from the llfa subject to standard
conditions seven trent water have
carried out sewer modelling and that's
confirmed that a development of up to
nine dwellings will have a very low
impact on the existing sewer network and
on this basis seven trent water have no
objections to the proposals subject
conditions
with regards to ecology the county
ecologist has no objection to these
proposals subject to conditions
and we've made amendments during the
life of the application to address
comments from the highways officer
and they also have no objections
in light of the further work carried out
by all parties since this application
was last put on a committee agenda in
january of this year it seems we're now
all in agreement that there is clear
evidence of a substantial shortfall in
the provision of self and custom-built
housing in this district
there are strong reasons to support
these development proposals as set out
in detail within your office's report
we're very close now to agreeing the
final details for the necessary 106
legal agreement which will control the
future marketing and occupancy of each
plot
in conclusion there's clear evidence the
council is not meeting its legal duty to
provide a sufficient number of
service plots
the site lies in a sustainable location
identified in the draft site allocations
plan as a suitable site for self-build
custom-built housing
there are no technical reasons to
justify refusal and your office's report
sets out in detail strong reasons why
these proposals should be supported we
therefore ask that permission is granted
thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
it looks quiet in that case thank you
very much for your time as well
councillor adam is not able to be here
tonight councillor kettle is kindly
deputized for him so we'll move to our
in lieu of ward member representative
you are neighbouring ward member i
understand to help you
okay thank you
absolutely well in that case you have
five minutes
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end over to you whenever you're
ready
[Music]
cancer adams gives his apologies and
asked me to be his substitute i'd like
to thank joe brooke for his
comprehensive report which clearly
demonstrates this is not an easy case
uh
he is clear this is a finally balanced
between be acceptable or not which he
concluded is just tilted towards
approval
does the committee agree with that
balance
this council describes the site from the
sdc's appeal hearing statement 2015
referencing this site specifically there
may be opportunities south of the
industrial state but avoiding the
pasture with willows ruby's meadow this
site the small pasture extreme mature
willow trees as well as uh remnant rich
and furrow this field is specifically
mentioned in the lcpe sensitivity test
to be avoided
why should it be avoided in 2015 but not
now
this application does not comply with
core strategy policies cs16 and cst15
not complying with cf-15 it must be
assessed against as10 which does not
consider small-scale developments
acceptable unless it is within the
built-up area boundary of an lsv this
application is not within the buab
the council's five-year housing supply
supplies we know is eight point four two
years and the village in lsp1 settlement
has delivered over 308 new dwellings
against a core strategy guideline of
113.
the application does not comply with the
cs5 landscape the site has been
specifically identified the evidence
based of the course strategy the
landscape substances sensitivity
assessment 2012 as a site to be avoided
for development
the schla indicates that mitigation
measures which would would have to be
made to make the site suitable
and the early appeal statement indicates
this cannot be achieved therefore
landscape is a material reason to refuse
the application does not comply with
long itchington neighbor neighborhood
plan policies noticeably h1 a point
accepted by mr brooke in attributing
significant weight to the neighbor
neighborhood plan
the only basis for approval
is the issue of self and custom build
housing
sdc's scb briefing paper published in
now may 22 states
the supply of scb plots is sufficient
based on those that have part one sill
exemption
this is certainly the case based on the
three-year rolling period specified in
jcb sorry scb regulations within which
sufficient plots should be provided to
equate to the number of people on the
register three years earlier
i continue
at first of april 2019 there were 111
people on the register while three years
hence the first of april 2022 a total of
205 scb plots
uh with part ones an exemption had been
provided
more than adequate our own policy team
consider the district clearly passes the
test the adequate promotion of sap
properties in may 2022
under the sill one test the problem
arises the still part two test which
only looks at those hazards which have
been completed or occupied
yes not all of those 205 houses have
been built but to ignore those approved
but not built would conflict with the
calculation of the five-year housing
land supply which is happy to include
approved but not dwellings in
calculating the figure
surely we cannot have one rule
uh for calculating the five-year housing
land supply and saying
they've been approved but not built but
have a converse interpretation when we
come to the
self build area
not building is in the hands of the
developers we have approved 205
dwellings but by focusing solely on the
sil2 test those occupied we are giving
control to developers to determine
policy
this has to be wrong
our policy team has determined we have
approved and i quoted their report
enough seb sites in the district to
satisfy demand they have just not yet
been built we cannot ignore the failure
of this application to comply with a
number of our key core structure
policies only to approve it based on
discounting scp supply by removing
unoccupied scb homes
i would remind members
we have an nppf and a core core strategy
to protect this district from
inappropriate development such as this
it is therefore really important that we
get the balance as joe has tried to do
in his report right
between
complying with the core strategy which
is still an important policy document
or whether we throw away the course
strategy and focus entirely on self
build and say whoopee self-build let's
let it go on a greenfield site with very
significant ecological environmental
issues
um and say let's focus entirely on
self-world and approve it my view is
that is wrong we should be focusing on
nppf the call strategy the legal tests
set out in this original self-build um
legislation are not the current
interpretation as put on in this paper
by mr brooke
thank you very much um any questions
from the committee
oh you made it yes councilman
yeah thanks jim um
council kettle you you you quoted quite
a few um policies there can you let me
know what they are again
of course saturday right
can you go slowly because uh
i can only write slowly if the chairman
will allow me yes
um
we have
um you'll be familiar with cancer our
core strategy of policies cs6 16 and
cs15 so
16
and 15 yeah
uh which you will you will recall we
just need the numbers we just need the
numbers don't worry that's all the
questions just give me the number just
give us the numbers you might have
forgotten
my colleagues
right
we then move on um
as10
yeah uh we then have the cs5 landscape
policy
where there is more enough evidence from
our own any other any others is that it
is that all the ones you listed um
i could get what i could get the whole
policy but if you like it
sorry about that mr chairman it's all
right
all right
any other questions
no thank you thank you kendall you are
released
all right okay let's uh move two points
of clarification
uh council jennings first
let's have a bit of a bit more
clarification on the interpretation of
self-built numbers please
i think the best way to do that is i
passed my policy colleagues
now that i'll take it with talking about
the the issue of supply and demand
information really at the end of the day
yeah well it's it's not a
straightforward issue i'm afraid uh it's
not gonna be a straightforward answer
either um as we've already heard that
the local planning authority has a legal
duty to provide sufficient self and
custom-built plots to satisfy demand i
set out in the register that's the
starting point
now
in terms of how you interpret supply and
demand data there's um paragraph 11
of the playing the
the ppg
which talks about the local planning
authority should use demand data from
the register in their area supported as
necessary by additional data from
secondary sources to understand and
consider future need for this type of
housing it's not an instruction as such
but then the paragraph does go on to
state that decision makers will need to
make reasonable assumptions using their
data to avoid double counting
so when um early on this year you
members may well remember that a tuscan
finish group was set up by over the
scrutiny committee of
officers and members to look at the
supply and demand issues amongst other
things to do with south and custom build
and this was one of the one of the areas
that was took up a lot of officer and
member
time in terms of what would be the most
appropriate way to settle what data we
use both on the supply and demand side
of things
we were concerned
when we did some research both on
appealing
decisions and on secondary supply issues
about the robustness of some of the
supplied data
um certainly there was a potential for
um the double counting that you the
paragraph 11 of the ppg states that we
shouldn't be doing
um also appealing inspectors seem on the
face of it not to be able to come to a
definitive answer themselves on it
in the fact that some um seem to suggest
that uh you people should be able to
consider just the part one cell
exemption form with the submitted with
their plan application that subsequently
gets permission and others are actually
saying that actually we should only
account about sealed part two which is
when the
the dwelling is actually completed and
occupied by the applicant
in fact uh we did in fact go for some
council opinion on this particular issue
ourselves
and the council opinion came about that
in their opinion that we should be doing
it on the sil part two calculation which
is the occupation which is why the the
figure of 30 dwellings in the briefing
note is so low as compared to the figure
that counselor kettle quoted so that is
the reason why we came up with a 30 and
then with the rolling program of 111
going back to the 2019 that's the gap
that we feel we have at the moment
i hope that
helps so just to clarify that
with sdc's interpretation and that's
coming from the task and finish group
um that we have a shortfall
it was through work that the tuscan
finnish group did alongside the advice
that we got from
the the council opinion but just as an
aside as an addition um
i actually uh was on
a very interesting workshop this morning
with that was held by the right to build
task force um that was actually on
specifically on appeals on self and
custom build
where they actually admitted themselves
that they put in their own words there
is a dichotomy between the legal duty
and the definition that local the
playing authorities have to wrestle with
there seems to be a contradiction
between the duty on local planning
authorities in relation to providing
permissions are set out in section 2a
paragraph 6c of the sale from custom
build housing out 2015 and the
definition of self and custom build in
relation to actually delivery so they
don't really marry up you've got the
duty given permissions but the
definition itself will custom build on
delivery so even there we're uh really
funny quite difficult to find
the right place to actually pitch it so
this is our
um way of pitching it based on facts
rather than conjecture
okay
i'll just follow on from that just to
confirm in my mind so there is a
based on our reckoning there's a
shortfall but based on any of the
reckonings there's still a short form
correct absolutely yes
whichever set of numbers you look at i
believe so yes thank you okay
uh council mills
for joe
joe can you um
confirm uh
the statement is outside the built-up
area boundary
yes or no
yeah yeah he's i decided to be uab i
have stated that within the report thank
you and can i second question mr
chairman thanks joe um
the uh where are we the public footpath
how
does that interfere with the new
development or you've
interviewed the footpath i think the
best way to show you if you could please
photos
so the public footpath there wouldn't be
any
removing the public footpath or
um in order to divert it
it simple cases they are public views
obtainable off the site as we stated in
the report
i do believe that the site would be
viewable name namely the rooftops so
that's where it is you can see there
that's the public footpath then
obviously you've got
cotton road and so forth which leads up
and out
thanks joe thank you
yes council reading
thank you chair um this is another kind
of in the numbers technical question
possibly if my understanding is right so
self self-build have a period of time to
be fulfilled and then they can become
open market housing is that correct
i think what we're talking about there
is more to the marking period marketing
period that might be within the section
106. okay so
on from that
if i have 10 uh 10 potential self builds
and perhaps two of them get
get self built so to speak the others go
on the open
market
do they still come off the total of self
builds that we've provided or do they
sort of drop the other way if you see
what i mean
if if any of the plots weren't sold off
within the marketing period and they
went on to the open market then the open
market dwellings would not then be sell
from custom bills so they wouldn't go
against those figures now
sorry but the planning commission
the outline planning permission would
still
persist so somebody could turn up and
build there but the the outline
permission would still stand but each
reserve matters would come in on each
individual plot
okay any other points of clarification
council jennings
and the marketing on this would be two
years
it had to be marketed as a self build
the custom built for two years before it
could go to open market well this was
one of the areas again that was
discussed uh
through offices and members through the
task and finish group in terms of what
the appropriate marketing period might
be for section 106 of this nature
because of course it's all very new it
started off with a nine month marketing
period
but again after doing research through
the task and finish group um
it transpired that the 9 to 12 month
period that seemed to be the norm that
when we did research on all the local
planning authorities were
actually relating to
sort of percentage applications on large
allocations so there'd be like five or
ten percent of x number on an allocation
within a settlement or built up area
boundary
our particular scenario here through the
six sub seven policy is slightly
different in the fact they're kind of
exception sites in the way they're
outside the building area boundaries so
there are allocations for a specific
purpose
so the task and finish group felt it
would be actually more appropriate in
our opinion to have a slightly longer
marketing period to give it the
opportunity to have it for the purpose
to which is being allocated
so follow-up question to that was so
should we be mindful to grant this could
we set that as a condition that is on
this particular
piece of land that is a 24 month period
in the recommendation in the report
um that would form part of
and just bring it up it would fall under
the
recommendation part um
a restricting and marketing of the
dwellings now the current site
allocations plan says that marketing
should be two years so it will be
covered by that part of the 106
agreement
excellent okay thank you okay
yes council curtis
i'm struggling with this i freely admit
um
were we minded to
grant this application it would be on
the basis
of it being custom and self-killed
and
if then after the 24 months
say only two plots have been cited the
customer self-doubt
surely that also exposes the floor
that there it actually isn't the demand
that we're being presented with
to have these custom self-built plots
and and
how can we
then because this is being put forward
as
for customer self-build i'm really
concerned that we'd end up with actually
effectively an open market development
so how can we actually stop that
happening if we're being told that we
should be granting this because it's
that customer self build unless we've
got an absolute guarantee that it
couldn't go on to the open market i
think you've asked your question you've
started to make a speech
there it love to you
i understand the point you're making
um however two years exists to give the
market an opportunity
to for people to come forward to pick up
those plots on this site and given the
level of demand that's in the the
documents
that have been discussed in the report
it it's highly likely
that all of those will be picked off
well before that two years as long as
the marketing is done properly and that
would form part of the legal agreement
that a proper marketing strategy is done
and monitored and that the council
regularly gets updates on that marketing
but
just to finish off if there were any
left at the end of that two years which
would be surprising given the evidence
um then they would fall to be
council mills you indicated yes yes
thanks mr champ um
it mentions it it's the emerging ndp
does that does that carry any weight on
this
yeah chris it the the document as a
whole carries significant weight it's in
the principal section um the examiner's
report's been submitted and it it looks
like it will proceed to referendum i
mean no data's been set to that so it's
sniff can weight as a whole but as i set
out in the principal section you have to
give the mate the important policies in
this case policy h1 in my opinion
moderate weight
because it doesn't specifically now deal
with self and custom build housing
thank you joe thank you um
now for further points for clarification
should we go to the debate then who
would like to start on this one
council jennings
it was interesting that about the demand
and i'm going to probably say something
then i'll come back in a bit later on
but the the demand for building plots
well they're like hens teeth like
yesterday i actually went online to have
a look at building plots which are
available in the district and i found
one
which had gone on the market
and i phoned them up and they said
um it went on
two days ago
and it uh it's got block viewings every
half an hour for three days this week
there's a huge demand for
for building plots i don't think and yet
i don't think any building plots which
you build in the district will end up as
um as market plots i think the demand is
huge
but i'll let someone else start debate
thank you council mills you're indicated
next says thanks richard i'm a great
champion of ndps and um
also uh
for me this outside the built-up area
boundary it does concern me this mr
chairman i'll um i have problems with it
but i'll wait to hear what everybody
else says at the moment on the debate
thank you thank you council hunts
seraphim
yes thank you chair um i have concerns
that uh long itchington
has 2.6 times the required number of
houses
also
to my mind self-built is not self-built
it's self-built for a while and then it
goes on the open market
being in the building trade all my life
i've known a lot of self builders and
they built a house that they want to
live in
now there could be people in the village
that want to build their own houses to
live in
but not on the open market that
just seems a backdoor way
of
building houses and calling themselves
buildings
so
i have reservations about them
anybody else want to speak at this point
councillor curtis
thanks chef um
i mean uneasy about a number of aspects
of this and
one of them is reading the
letter
from emw
where
there does seem to be
a conflict between
um the council's interpretation of
what goes on to the register
or measuring and
the law according to this letter and
where
the uh
the house building act customers
2015 but i know we all have this
um authorities must give suitable
development permission it doesn't state
that they need to be built and occupied
um
yet this report which is is very lengthy
and very thorough
um it does seem
on page 5455 for example
um
it seems to place us
a lot of weight
on
the district council's measurement
joe says you know i noticed there is a
shortfall of available plots he gives
this shortfall then significant weight
i again uh
on page 55
in all probability
a significant shortfall
to which significant weight is attached
i feel you know if we were
to go down that route
if we would be leaving ourselves open to
challenge and that that does concern me
those i can't reconcile
those two different positions at the
moment
go on council jennings in our way
and i know we're working on this on the
policy
at the moment it's obviously very
important that we get this in place
um and obviously this is a complicated
one but we have a legal duty to provide
self-built plots in whichever way you
interpret the data there there's a
shortfall and we need to
we need to get that need to get the
numbers in um
i know it's slightly controversial here
but i shall uh
propose that we go along with the
officer's recommendations
um and grant this
i'm gonna i'll say my piece you beat me
to it actually i think and you've said
mostly what i was going to say
i think the concerns that have been
raised so far about the methodology the
way in which we arrive at the numbers
and the way we determine what's on the
list that's available
uh for for the uh
for herself bill
i mean i asked the question importance
of clarification no matter which version
which which way you look at this either
way there's a short form in this
authority we don't have enough um enough
self-build properties on online ready to
go
and as far as
that's for me where where this this lies
and
no matter how you look at them at the
dot methodology and i'm by the way
satisfied with the way our officers have
handled this they seem to have done a
huge amount of research on how to how to
quantify how to come up with the numbers
for this and lots of lots of research
and and i think their their reckoning is
sound
um
so i i agree with council jennings i'll
be seconding his proposal to to grant
this application
um but counselor curtis i noticed you
sort of in
yeah shifting uncomfortably if you'd
like to come in i think
it is open to interpretation the the
number of plots available
i think depending on which figures you
take and i know i could see councillor
kettle waving on obviously i can't ask
him again for his figures but
it is not
um
it is open to dispute the number of
things i don't think as a committee we
can accept that it is absolutely cast
iron guaranteed that there is a
shortfall i think also
there is this um
concern over the the ecological nature
of this field which we haven't actually
really considered and i think you know
this is a this is meadowland it's been
untouched for generations really
i've got the policy somewhere but i'm
sure you'll know what i'm referring to
we should be protecting this area not
building on it
anybody else want to come in on the
debate at this point councillor fleming
just a quick follow-up from what david
was saying i mean we've got pages hit
full pages of bullet points about sort
of mutes and
uh
ancient farmland and all of these sort
of things but what confuses me then is
you look in and you see that
ecology have made no objections except
for a couple of conditions and
it it does confuse because you know
we're trying to a protect land that
we're supposed to not supposed to build
on and i think even we said that
ourselves some years ago that this land
shouldn't be built up
and it's almost like a pressure that's
come along from from the self builds to
the register and whatever else and on a
personal level with self built similar
to what peter was saying earlier
i thought the self builder was when a
guy bought bought a plot of land and
engaged engaged the brickie and grazer
roofer and whatever and these sort of
shell schemes and whatever else seemed
to be
circumnavigating some some laws and
rules that you know we've worked hard to
try and sort of keep
so i'm very very on the fence with this
one it's not one it's not something
that's one of my favorites to be
brutally honest
just because we have anecdotal
experience of i know a bloke who was a
builder he built his own house and
that's a self-built well that's anecdote
isn't it that's not cast iron that's not
there's no evidence base there that's
just what we know because we've got some
experience in knowing a bloke who built
a house look what we've got here is a
definition of of our of custom build and
self-built houses that's what our
officers have determined here so i'm
sorry i don't think it's for this
committee to start trying to redefine
what that means based on what we know
um
if if we have concerns about ecology i
think we should explore those a bit
further i am i'm concerned with us
trying to come up with again a different
view of the methodology and how we count
the numbers of houses as a committee
again that one i don't think really for
us to sit there and try to hack away at
the numbers is a job for this committee
i think you need to listen to what our
officers have said and they have given
us our steer and our guide point for
what they think is appropriate for the
numbers of houses and they've
recommended
by the way on both sides of this they've
said this there's a shortfall no matter
how you count the numbers anyway
so i think really if we've got concerns
they really we should hear what you
think about the ecology as well because
we've not gone into much detail on that
counselor curtis do you want to commit i
will go into detail on that very point
thank you chair um so um page four of
the
long itchington parish council report
ecology and diversity this is a highly
unusual site an undisturbed hay meadow
that has not been plowed within living
memory or subjected to modern intensive
agricultural methods the site is rich in
wildlife and has significant potential
to enhance biodiversity i wonder even
within such a large rural district as we
have here
how many
building plots
would be
undisturbed pay meadow not plowed within
living memory
and on page 44 of joe's excellent report
he does say that said i do acknowledge
that the application will cause an
adverse impact by urbanizing the
currently undeveloped field and policy
cs5 states the landscape character and
quality of the district will be
maintained by ensuring that development
takes place in a manner in i'll
re-emphasize that
the character and quality of the
district landscape
will be maintained by ensuring
that development takes place in a manner
that minimizes and mitigates its impact
if we build or if we allow building on
an undisturbed hay meadow that has not
been plowed within living memory or
subjected to modern intensive
agricultural methods that cannot be
replaced ever
you know in extinction i would be
dramatic
extinction is forever we would lose that
very rare sight forever and i think
that's something we really need to
consider
very carefully are there other options
available to us for bill for building
plots thank you chair thank you
council jennings
as we're going into debate um
i i tend to go with the expert's opinion
and
i read here warwickshire county council
ecology no
objection about to say that you need
houses yeah and they've got to be built
somewhere and they get built on land
oh you're going to clarify something
carefully i'm just concerned that
members
might not fully appreciate everything
here
in terms of what county ecology have
said what county ecology have said about
the site and there are independent
experts is it semi-improved neutral
grassland in moderate condition
it could be in far better condition
but for that reason they've calculated
that there would be a loss to
biodiversity of 2.25 units
but as you'll see in the report that can
be offset by the maintenance and the
maintenance strategy in perpetuity for
the maintenance of that field to the
north you see there and then that field
will be maintained
in an even better way than the one is
currently so any harm would be offset so
there's no evidence of harm on ecology
thank you
that's a valuable point actually so if
you can offset something make it
protected somewhere else
that's uh a long-term plan um anybody
else wishing to come in on the debate
um
do the officers ever take any notice of
the neighborhood plan
is is it worth having a neighbourhood
plan
you know housing needs and well i think
you know that they do but
that is taken into account you'll see
the several pages in the report
dedicated to the neighborhood plan by
law we've had to moderate the amount of
weight we give to we can't give it
significant weight but we've done
exactly the same for our own core
strategy for the reason set out in the
report because they don't grapple with
the issue of self-build but i would
refute the suggestion that we don't give
acknowledgement to it because we put
seven or eight pages in the report on it
okay
all right right let's uh let's push to a
vote shall we it's been proposed and
seconded that we grant this application
um
in accordance with the recommendation of
course and the subject to 106
agreement as well let's go to the vote
all those in favor of granting please
show
that's too german those against
five germans okay
we're gonna need an alternative
proposition
people who just put their hands up
anybody got something to weigh in with
councilman can i say something to
chairman yeah i mean um
they do have an emerging ndp
uh they've met in the housing news
survey i i i believe
um and it's um again outside the boa bu
a b
and you know it does fly in the face of
our course strategy the policies so
mr chairman
cs1516 well done mr
thank you
do we have a proposition proposal
you propose refusal
thank you
okay
do we have a second councillor curtis
okay we can need are you content with
you've had enough reasons why john is
flashing out further
i haven't really got the
full reason there
and perhaps it would help if i just
explain to members
the state of play with our core strategy
because you're absolutely right it is
contrary to our core strategy because
it's outside the bill to pay a boundary
but that's not the end of the story it
would be the end of the story for open
market
but in this case our core strategy
doesn't grapple with the issue of
self-built that's coming along later and
for that reason you have to look at
paragraph 11 in the mppf which explains
what your waiting exercise should then
be and that's why officers have
moderated their weight
and i would recommend that members do
the same
and give a lesser waiting as we've done
which means
that because of that that is why we're
outweighing it with the need to provide
self build
but we've got insec sorry mr chairman
i've got to go
personally i think we've got to take
into the account of uh
outside the built-up area boundary i
mean
it's happened in my village where it's
gone long
so one of the reasons you propose is is
outside of the area bill's parent
boundary
council is coming in it is contrary to
policy cs
hold on for that one
okay
it's okay next last now next one was
contrary to cs5 policy cs5 that's
another reason that counts cuts going
forward
um yeah um
before i move on to the cs5 point just
pick up on that buab point because i
would also ask members to bear in mind
that the emerging sap although it's got
limited weight at its early stage
it does identify
that site's adjacent to build a pair of
boundaries which is that what this is uh
will be acceptable for self-built so
there's also that to weigh in the
balance on that build up area boundary
argument
um
cs5 in terms of the land
gated and that the views into the site
from the footpath will be nothing more
than than rooftops
um and that that doesn't outweigh all
the other matters that we've weighed in
favor of it
but members are entitled to take a
different view within the bounds of
reasonableness
right it's um
been raised with me councillor kettle
would like to come back in to raise a
point of clarification which he is
allowed to do within the rules
but i'm going to have to restrict
councillor kettle apologies it don't
just come to me that you're trying to
indicate that you'd like to speak again
um so if you want come forward you have
to restrict your comments to the point
that you think that i made a mistake on
but if you'd like to come forward and
speak on that
thank you very much mr chairman i will
just go back to what i quoted in my
report
um that in the
in the policy document
issued by this council may 22
um the wording says at first of april
2019 there were 111 people on the
register while three years hence at the
first of april 22 a total of 205 scb
plots with part one said exemption
doesn't deal part two now under that
measure
there was more than enough supply and i
just wanted to cr to put that
to you because i think you actually said
under any
uh measure there was a shortfall and i
think quite clearly the paper published
by this council says it was not a
shortfall under that under that
methodology well i thank you for the
clarification um
i was taking i've been taking advice
from officers all night
that was the basis on which i made that
comment and i think the record will show
that quite clearly right okay um
wording of this recommendation since we
need to we need to tidy this up don't we
we've got richard have you got a sort of
a summary of this in terms of how you
feel counts the committee
i've heard two possible reasons for
refusal here uh one i would say is very
weak one is he's a little bit stronger
that the weak one is the bilderberry
boundary one and i won't i won't draw
the point out anymore
uh for the reasons i've given the the
visual impact one is stronger because
it's cs5 and there are visual impacts
because it's on the edge of the village
and there are views of it a bit limited
from that public footpath
um some members members may want to
consider their their views on that point
i don't know if they do um committee
have you got anything further to add
yes just
clarification following council of
kettles comments just then
does richard does
does that figure that counselor kendall
has just given us have any does that
impact on our decision
in some helpful way
um
it doesn't alter my opinion and i'm sure
it doesn't alter the opinions of my
colleagues in policy
because it all depends on the secondary
data if you move
if you start taking into account
secondary data on one side you have to
take an account on the other and you
just move that balance
up and down but you've still got a
shortfall and that's why
my colleague here said
whichever way you look at it you can end
it with a shortfall but those figures do
seem to demonstrate that there isn't a
shortfall
so
well we are where we are um i think
we've we have debated long and long
enough now um we've got our two clear
reasons um one which we think is a week
one which things slightly stronger
uh are members content to go to a vote
on this
at this point and i'm looking for any
nods around the room or do you want to
keep talking
all right okay i just need to clarify
that recommendation again if you just
clarify that for me the recommendation
very clearly so we're not we're voting
on
so the first reason would be
simply that it's contrary to the core
strategy and outside of the bilterberry
boundary
and the second one would be that it
would cause
harm to the visual amenities of this
edge of village location particularly
when viewed from the public footpath
proposer is happy with that
secondary's happy with that
okay in that case we'll go to the vote
all those in favor of the of the amended
recommendation which now to refuse based
on what we've just heard please show
five german and those against
two chairmen
therefore the committee uh resolves to
yes
it's gonna be the second part because oh
so the second part is based on the
and because i know that you're all fully
up to speed and reading the update
sheets the second part of that is that
we have to take a vote on uh on the
possibility of the appeal as well
um all those so that the up should i
take the same proposals you're proposing
refusal on that grounds as well
accounts
exactly based on the appeal
all those in favor of that please show
that's five channels thank you and those
against
two chairmen
you content yes thank you the committee
therefore resolves to refuse application
reference twenty one slash zero two
eight two five four slash out
five minute break just get it to the
toilet everybody and just have a get a
coffee five minutes be prompt thank you
everybody
hi everybody can we take our seats again
please
counselor curtis
thank you
okay we're all back so i'll just give a
second for the uh stream to go live it
is live still there we go it's up and
running
right let's continue shall we uh we go
to our final application this is item
six
and is application reference twenty one
slash zero three five four four slash
ful and is uh sweet acre the orchard
wickson road excel uh the end proposal
is for a replacement dwelling to be
itself to be self-built with associated
works presenting officer amy flute amy
over to you
thank you chairman
the site donated by the black dot is
with an x-hull and all other settlement
the application site edged red contains
an existing dwelling its associated
cartilage and surrounding agricultural
land the site's access is within the
sorry the site access is within the
conservation area however the proposed
development is to the north of the
conservation area boundary a grade two
listed building is cited opposite the
site's access
a public footpath is sited um to the
west of the application site and
planning commission is sought for a
self-build replacement dwelling
a certificate of lawfulness established
the existing dwelling and its associated
cartilage as lawful due to the passage
of time in this open countryside
location as indicated on this plan here
there have also been two applications
approved and committed development
rights for extensions to the existing
dwelling one raising the roof of the
existing building and one extending out
from the existing building
all are within the approved
sorry all are within the area approved
by the lawful development certificate
edgered on the plans which can be seen
the proposed dwelling will be cited
further north into the open countryside
on agricultural land outside of the
existing dwellings lawful cartilage the
dwelling will be a two-story
subterranean owl-shaped building
constructed from masonry timber and a
slate roof the existing dwelling which
can be seen here will be removed
following the complete completion of the
replacement dwelling further north
an artist impression of the proposed
dwelling can now be seen please note
that this image does not accurately
demonstrate the parking and turning area
to the building's frontage
the left image is taken on the existing
access looking towards the highway where
the grade ii listed building can be seen
the right image is taken from the access
road looking in a north-westerly
direction towards the application site
the existing dwelling can now be seen
and as you can see the land level rises
in a northerly direction
and this image is looking in a southerly
direction back towards the existing
dwelling and again you can see how the
land level falls
and finally this image shows the
approximate location of the proposed
dwelling
chairman i am mindful that there is a
pressing need for self-build plots
however the benefits of the proposal do
not outweigh the harm which would arise
by virtue of the significant impact upon
the character of the ardent special
landscape area and rural setting as a
result of the size of the replacement
dwelling which is significantly larger
and it being cited in the open
countryside chairman it is recommended
that planning commission is refused for
the reasons as detailed within the
committee report there is also is a note
on the update sheet thank you
thank you amy um we go to our first
speaker then councillor adrian harvey
from exhale parish council
welcome
evening
right so you have three minutes if you'd
like before if you remain seated at the
end for any questions and we'll give you
a warning uh at the last 30 seconds of
your time if that's right
over to you
right then
the council as well as obviously as we
represent the uh
community we fully support adam and his
wife jenny in this application
adam is third generation
in the village
and they also need a larger family home
and the main thing there is nothing
available in the village for that sort
of size
and also obviously the cost of living in
that village
the garden area associated with the
uh existing property
is where the new dwelling is going to be
built
so
there's no expanse beyond that
um
so it's all going to be within the
confines of the existing village
and there's the council
we've all looked at it and we welcome
the size of it
and also the design the new design of
the property
and because it's going to be built into
the land
the slides you've just seen yes you can
see that
from
within their land
but you can't say that from outside of
their land
that's all i have thank you that's all
right thank you very much do we have any
questions from the committee
oh getting off lightly that's great
thank you very much then thank you
okay we moved to the next speaker we've
got gary moss and mr reed applicant in
the agent come on up
hello
sorry chairman if it's okay mrs reed's
going to speak on that
don't worry about it take your time so
how we've got three minutes between you
are you gonna speak or i think the um
mrs reed will speak first setting out a
bit of the local then i'll just deal
with some of the technical points follow
about a minute and two minutes something
like that okay
right in that case i'll let you work out
your timings but that's fine and um
if you just press the button in the
middle
there you go that case over to you okay
thank you
members this application is technically
for replacement dwelling although the
council have confirmed it's a self-built
property
as has been discussed quite heavily
today
i think
the officers have identified that there
is a shortfall in self-build housing in
this case we have a definite local
person looking to build their own home
for their own needs and their family in
the village where they live
in terms of the cartilage issue
albeit the red line was shown smaller
it is clear that the garden
is in use for over 10 years and that the
properties is actually situated within
that and within the confines
in terms of the size and visual impact
the client has a large family needs the
accommodation and there are no other
options available we've looked at
permitted development and extensions and
it doesn't work members would have seen
the pictures of the house it's clearly
not in the state whereby it is suitable
for modern day living and definitely
does not meet the climate change
ideology that this council works to
interestingly
none of these concerns objections would
apply if this had come in as a brand new
self-built development within the
confines of the village
i note the earlier officers approval for
the
item that was removed and this
reinforces my point 30 seconds
in view of the self-build argument
short for the significant environmental
economic and social benefits
we believe that this development is
compliant with policy when considering
the self-build elements and would cause
and would outweigh any harm
that it justifies as you've heard from
both the parish council
and hopefully from the ward member thank
you
that is remarkably good timing you had
five seconds to spare between the two of
you okay do we have any questions please
from the committee councillor um
jennings first thing council curtis as
the expert
why didn't you recommend your clients to
build within the existing cartilage
sorry councillor
what
as as the expert um did you recommend to
your client to build to site the plot
within the curtain of existing cartilage
my
well
two points firstly the clients want to
maintain the home whilst they're
hopefully building their new home there
isn't physical space within the
cartilage to do so so there would have
to be some other form whether it's a
mobile home or something bring into site
so that was the one issue the second
issue i would say is
the application for the lawful
development certificate established
lawful use of the cabin as a residential
dwelling
it never considered the issue of garden
land and whilst i accept in a technical
term the cartilage is an area tight
around a building
it is clear
that the garden areas confirmed by the
parish council has been used as garden
for in excess of 10 years the applicant
has lived on this site since 2012
so from my point of view we felt it
clearly constituted garden in lawful
land use terms
not technically cursilage if you take
the red line but the key factor is it
was within the confines of the village
and clearly that's been supported by the
parish council
thank you council curtis
um
were the committee minded to to grant
once the
new dwelling had been built what would
happen to
the existing dwelling and site there on
perhaps you could let us know
um
the application is clear in the fact
that that building would be removed
demolished so there would be there
wouldn't be a second dwelling retaining
on site it would be
and would then be um
go back to the garden land
or it would remain as part of the plot
yes it would be within the garden and
within the client's ownership
any other questions from the committee
no
in that case thank you both for your
time much appreciated oh sorry couchhead
serif and sorry apologies sorry hold on
go for it
will this be a truly self-built house
right
and
you are going to live there and not sell
it on
okay okay
thank you i was gonna refer to the uh
the applicant and also the parish
council who obviously know known the
family for
three generations i believe it was for
adams so the client so yeah there's no
intention of anything else happening
okay
in that case if we're absolutely clear
you're both three thank you very much
okay um
go to our ward member councillor cargill
anne
welcome councillor
okay
perfect well you have three uh five
minutes thank you very much indeed
remain seated for any questions at the
end over to you thank you very much
members um right the refusal revolves
around the cartilage encroachment in the
open countryside and the size of the
building in relation to it being a
replacement building
it is within the be without outside the
the buav of course finally the impact
into the
sla is brought into question
first the size is appropriate for a
growing family
uh as you can see behind me if it was
defined only as a self-built property
then in all likelihood its scale would
be acceptable the engineering works are
necessary so the family can live in
their current home or the new ones being
constructed it'd be very expensive for a
large family to have to live in a
caravan during the construction phase
after construction the old dwellings to
be demolished becoming the garden
effectively swapping it around at your
point
you've heard about the cartilage element
of the application
it is outside the official cartilage of
the house however would still be part of
their garden which has been in use for
over 10 years that's important
this implies it forms the settlement
confines or boundary
with regard to the impact on the sla the
site is not visible from the road or any
public footpath the building is due to
be partially buried
minimizing visual impact even more
the nearest neighbors stated that they
cannot see the building and are
supportive of the application i
therefore conclude that there is no or
extremely limited impact on the sla
the
applicants and family have lived in the
village many years have just heard so it
is local need it is their home and where
their business is located having the
home adjacent to the business has many
advantages as you can imagine
significant environmental benefits can
be demonstrated in this build something
i would like to see more of and i'm sure
you all too would
semi burying the property will improve
the thermal efficiency and with the use
of air or ground source heating
eliminate the need for a gas supply
the officer's report states that this is
self-built as we have heard we are sure
to sell bills and as such the
appropriate weight should be afforded to
this application
in this case and just to answer the
question again it is a genuine self
build not a simply way to circumvent sil
the applicant works in the timber
business and wants to build certain
elements of the property himself
in summary the npps is not conflicted
likewise i do not believe it conflicts
with as10 in causing harm to the
character of the area
i feel it does not conflict with cs20
part c as the existing house will be
demolished after construction
returning to the kirkland
issue i believe that the new build into
the existing garden is proportionate and
given the need for the family to have
somewhere to live during the
construction
the materials proposed are accepted as
suitable it is not within the
conservation area and receives
overwhelming support from the community
members as always this is planning
balance this is not a bad property being
built in a small village just a resident
wishing to continue living in their
village i note that the both of the
previous applications at self-build
element was considered afforded
considerable weight
even against the objections of the pc
in this case there is full support and
no objections
i don't know if you want me to read this
little bit from the previous application
but it does say that nonetheless as10
does not make any reference in respect
to self-build or custom house building
consequently i consider that the policy
is inconsistent with national policy
guidance and legislation and it does not
address the council's legal obligation
to maintain a three-year rolling supply
of self-building custom held held
buildings
i think it's because this is being
judged as a replacement dwelling but
referred to in the report of self-built
so confusing
okay members as i said this is a
planning balance and a very tricky one
for you
in this case i believe that there are
multiple grounds to go against the
officer's recommendation and i would ask
you to grant this application thank you
thank you very much for the whole minute
to spare as well okay do we have any
questions from the committee
none
well
that case council cargill thank you very
much for your time as well
right
that's all our speakers should we go to
points of clarification councillor
jennings then mills
there have been a number of references
to the garden being
used for 10 years what are the
implications of this please
um so i think one thing to point out is
in terms of the garden um we we don't
have any evidence to demonstrate that
the garden has been used for that period
of time so we don't have any lawful
development certificates which have been
granted to demonstrate that so as
officers um i would consider that um the
land around the the existing building
that wasn't considered a part as part of
the lde would be in agricultural at this
at the present time it's as it's lawful
use as part of the assessment of the um
lawful development certificate for the
dwelling and the immediate land around
the building and the officer report did
make reference to um garden area and
stated that um the land outside of that
area hadn't hadn't been considered as
part of that application and as i say
there's been no other applications for
coming to demonstrate
whether or not that land has been used
continuously for the ten year period to
be considered lawful
okay council mills thank you thank you
jim i was going to ask sam
saw the same question i'll go into
something else uh the materials of the
house um i was looking at what what are
the materials
um so the materials proposed are
um so to be masonry um and timber for
the walls and slate tiles for the roof
and wood would affect upvc effect
windows so if members were minded to
approve then we would propose the
standard condition so that we can get
the material samples and details um
prior to obviously them being built
sorry mr uh so that was
a mixture of tim
um so the documentation submitted says
masonry and timber for the walls slate
tiles for the roofs and wood would
affect upvc affect windows
so you said did you say wood effect so
it will either be wood or upvc would
affect windows but we can if members are
minded to um
go against officer recommendation a
materials condition can be imposed and
we can secure that detail to make sure
it's appropriate for the landscape and
character thank you very much
i think council hence
oh yeah thank you amy could you put up
the picture showing the garden
you haven't got any pictures of fencing
of the garden or anything not have you
so this this image is um looking north
so there is um a timber fence and then
the other boundary treatments are
vegetation and then as you can see
there's a timber fence here as well
yeah
you didn't look how old the fencing was
did you
no okay
okay any other points clarification
no
all right let's go to the debate then he
wants to kick us off on this one
any thoughts
council mills yeah
thanks mr chairman um i have to say
quite i quite like the look of it and
the um of the building itself
um
the family obviously
look at the family of the
scout troop there i think they probably
do need a larger house and where they're
living at the moment um
at the moment i'm quite in favor of it
mr chairman so i'll listen to what other
people have to say thank you
counselor seraphim yeah i feel in favor
because if it's a true self-build
i will always support that and if the
family are going to live there they've
lived there for 10 years i think that's
um
good thank you
councillor curtis just
right here thank you and
i understand the objection from
from the officer to a good report
and particularly regarding the fact that
this the new property would be built
adjacent
but bearing in mind the families need to
have somewhere to live
during the rebuild it seems to me that
that is
that we could take that into account
thank you
councillor jennings
well i think we also have to look at the
technical aspects of this and
to me the application isn't quite right
um
it should it should have gone in as a
self build not a replacement strat slash
self build which seems to have been sort
of tagged on afterwards
um
i would be happier should if this
application came back
as a self-build
fairpoint
councilor fleming
now reading through the uh the reports
and uh
the parish council supporting can't be
seen from the road isn't visible has no
visual impact on anybody else
and
it's from that perspective and summing
up what everybody else has said um i'd
be quite in favor of this job as well
thank you
thank you the award members trying to
get my attention is it a point of
clarity on what's been said i can't
allow you to make any further statement
other than that
answer council jennings yes section 106
could be applied to make sure itself
built
thank you
we will clarify that with our officers
if that's okay as well um
do you want to have a think about that
we'll come back to you are you ready to
speak now
okay
if members were minded to approve given
the scale of this development we
consider that that would be able to be
done via condition we wouldn't need a
section 106 as it is just one unit
so it would go forward as a
as a self build
yeah i'm just confident it would
effectively be a personal permission to
the applicants they would be the self
builders because we know who they are at
this stage we could do it that's why we
don't need a 106.
and would meet our criteria for what to
self-build is undergoing legislation yes
because they've obviously had primary
input into the design of it so it
already meets it as long as it's those
that they that build it and crucially
adds to our self-built numbers yes thank
you okay um any anybody else on the
debate at this point
no
i'm i'm aware we've not got a
proposition
we've got a lot of people in favor and
no proposition who wants to go go with
it for the uh the current jim
i'm just echoing what bill's saying
i mean i'm in favor of it uh mr chairman
um
yeah
parish council in favor of it
members in favor of it uh i can't say it
does any harm to the area
um what else can i say is that a
proposition yes mr chairman thank you
that we accept thank you that we approve
uh do i have a second for that okay
council and seraphin
right let's confirm some reasons then um
we need we need our reasons for going
against the officer's recommendation oh
can we talk about conditions after yeah
we'll cut we'll come to conditions after
so our reasons for going against
officers recommendation i look to people
who've spoken already
the one i've noted down so far is that
we
from what people have said uh you have
said that it's sort of hidden from from
public view so i'm choosing to believe
that means that you think that it would
not cause uh any visual harm to the
rural character of the area
uh are we getting nods are you happy
with that or not
okay
um
well i don't think i've got anything
other than that actually i've heard you
say so far other than you don't
other than you feel it's
acceptable
just like it mr chairman at the moment
i know we're not allowed to say it i'm
just stretching my head
it it just it's just the officers to see
if they've picked up on anything in the
decade as well i
say that again counts curtis policy as10
is supportive of replacement dwellings
subject to not causing inappropriate
harm to the character of the area or
neighboring properties
oh yeah i can see where you're going
with that sounds good
[Music]
i've heard what members have said about
it not being harmful to the landscape
that's fine that that effectively is
neutral because we would expect all
developments to do that
um that the thing i have i'm struggling
to outweigh is policy cs20 covers
replacement dwellings and it says
um that it shouldn't be materially
larger and should be within the
cartilage so i could probably just do
with some guidance from members on on
their thoughts on that point because at
the moment i've only got so far it's
neutral on landscape arm which is fine
but
just wonder what members think about
cs20 in the materially larger point
well it does say
sorry chair yeah and
within the lawful cartilage of the
existing dwelling a nest significant
environmental benefits
would result and i think we are hearing
that there would be significant
environmental benefits from the horses
the pulse
the ground source heat pump all the
horse ground seat pump
there's probably something there
um
there's probably something there i mean
i'm not going to labor the point i
wouldn't say that's the heat pump
significant because that's the sort of
thing we expect on all developments now
um but it is yeah it's a benefit
can we say that because it's so uh
because because the way in which the
building's been designed to be partially
underground
that we that we think that it holds some
significant weight in terms of the yes
we accept the size is noticeably larger
but great efforts have been taken to try
and conceal that size by putting half it
underground
does that make yeah i think yeah i'm
happy to go
yes and also i mean the the cs20
officers know the existing dwelling is a
log cabin not suitable for retention
because of its construction but
presumably there will also be a greater
impact against the environment
were the existing building retained
rather than replacing no i think
sorry i don't know i think we've got to
stick to the proposal rather than what's
there i don't know what do you think
yeah i mean i think you're right to
bring the existing building into play
because obviously that has an impact of
its own and if you judge that this is a
better solution then that's that can be
an environmental benefit
okay
okay
um
i think we need to look at conditions
are there any conditions
our proposal would place yeah mr
chairman there was a mention of upvc um
what do you think of that would look no
go
yeah so first of all
i'm guessing the standard conditions
which you can go through on that one and
then we'll see if we can amend those for
you that way yeah so i have a list that
i prepared if this happens so um the
standard time limit plans
now i have um
given obviously the levels across the
site i do think we would need a
pre-commencement condition from the
agreement of the applicant the applicant
is here tonight so we could maybe ask
them now um to see whether they would um
be prepared to agree a pre-commencement
condition so that we can get ensure that
we know what's happening to the existing
and what's proposed with the land levels
materials
condition development in accordance with
the tree survey a hard and soft
landscaping condition the self-filled
condition which richard and i spoke
about a short while ago
a condition
which basically states that within two
months of the occupation of the new
dwelling the
existing dwelling um is to be removed
from the site
um and then other conditions relating to
climate change checklist bins water but
electric vehicle charging points
detailed wording obviously delegated to
officers uh council mills did you want
to talk about the materials on the
windows yes yeah oh sorry mr yeah
could we say that um
uh it would be
timber as as opposed to
to a mixture of timber and upvc
my my my only concern with that would be
is that a reasonable stipulation to
place in the in well we want this
and it didn't look i'm guessing do you
think that's going to impact the visual
im is that going to affect the visual
impact of this new property given that
we're trying to make it eco-friendly and
upvc would be far more efficient
but it's plastic
it will look like wood
unless you go up and tap it
have a think council jennings
i think it'd be unreasonable
very unreasonable to say that they
couldn't have upvc
it's uh
it's material which a lot of windows are
built out of whether it's
upvc or aluminium
um the modern windows all have their
benefits um i don't think we should get
bogged down
i think
yeah i think the specifics of the
materials delegated to officers anyway
they will do that cats mills is this the
hill you want to die on over
right over the upper rotten lot all
right okay
all right
okay
um yeah an unusual situation any
pre-commencement condition of which
levels really ought to be
pre-commencement we need the agreement
of the applicants right
do you want a moment or do you need to
talk to them about that i'm happy to do
it an open committee okay trying to come
we're not going to bring you up here
we're going to take
a literally five minutes germans richard
come and chat with you over there for a
second and then just to clear everything
up to make sure you're happy okay so
five minutes i'll ask members not to go
wandering if that's okay want to get
this over and done with
um
yes the applicants agreeable that
they're also agreeable to a note
saying timber
for the windows yeah
okay um
let's get back let's get started again
so uh richard can you just report the
what you've discussed yeah just for the
benefit of all members um the
applicant's happy with the
pre-commencement condition around levels
they've also indicated they're happy
with an informative around the use of
timber for fenestration
council mills if you would like us to
add an if you would like us to add a
note only we can do that to help okay
council mills i take it that's a yes
then okay right
thank you okay so we've can you read out
just precisely what the reasons that
we're going against the officer's
recommendation so i can go with that
um
yeah
members have considered that the uh the
proposal isn't harmful overall to the
character of the area and particularly
the arden special landscape area
um
furthermore
whilst it is materially larger against
cs20 there are significant enviro
environmental benefits in the form of um
the ground source heat pump and the fact
that the design is better than the
existing and therefore it does make cs20
thank you
um
right
we can go to the vote can't we so the
prop the application's been proposed
that we grant in accordance with the set
of conditions that we've agreed
all those in favor of granting please
show
that's six chapman those against and
abstentions one chairman okay in that
case the committee resolves to grant
application reference
three
21
four four slash f u of ful that
concludes business for the evening thank
you very much meeting
no admissions no urgent business meeting
is closed thank you everybody
you